ORDERLY TRANSITION FOR SECRETARY
OF STATE DESIGNATE MIKE POMPEO.
>> Tucker: BRIT HUME JOINS US
TONIGHT.
AN AWFUL GOING ON.
I WANT TO GO IN ORDER.
FIRST TILLERSON, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS?
>> WELL, IT DOES SHOW YOU CANNOT
DISAGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT ON
MAJOR FOREIGN POLICY
MAJOR FOREIGN POLIIE
MAJOR FOREIGN POLIIES
MAJOR FOREIGN POLIIES A
MAJOR FOREIGN POLIIES AND
MAJOR FOREIGN POLIIES AND L
MAJOR FOREIGN POLIIES AND LIS
MAJOR FOREIGN POLIIES AND LIST
FOREVER.
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT CAN BE
A BULKY PLACE.
THIS PRESIDENT IS NOT THE FIRST
PRESIDENT GETTING HIS ARMS AND
IT AND GETTING CONTROL OF IT.
THERE'S A GOOD ARGUMENT OF
WHETHER TILLERSON DID EITHER
OVER THERE.
BUT THERE'S ALWAYS THIS QUESTION
WITH SECRETARIES OF STATE, ARE
THEY REPRESENTING THE STATE
DEPARTMENT TO THE WHITE HOUSE OR
THE WHITE HOUSE TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
THE FEELING IN THIS WHITE HOUSE
IS THAT TILLERSON WAS A CREATURE
OF THE BUILDING, ALTHOUGH HE
WASN'T THOUGHT TO BE ALL THAT
POPULAR.
SO HIS DAYS WERE PROBABLY
NUMBERED.
IT'S REGRETTABLE.
IT MEANS WE'LL HAVE A PERIOD OF
INSTALLED.
THE SAME WILL BE TRUE FOR HIS
DEPUTY WHO IS SUPPOSED TO TAKE
OVER AT CIA.
AND THAT LEAVES A PERIOD IN
WHICH THE AGENCIES ARE NOT
FUNCTIONING IN THE WAY THEIR NEW
LEADERS WILL WANT THEM TO.
IT'S REGRETTABLE AT THE EARLY
STAGES THAT THEY'RE STILL
GETTING THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN
PLACE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT IS
REGRETTABLE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE REPORT
THE REPUBLICAN -- MAJORITY
REPORT FROM THE INTEL COMMUNITY
YESTERDAY THAT FOUND NO
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND PUTIN?
>> I THINK IT'S PROBABLY CORRECT
THAT COMMITTEE DID FIND
THAT COMMITTEE DID FIND NO
COLLUSION.
I WOULD NOTE, TUCKER, THIS IS IN
THE FACE OF THE CRITICISM THAT
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE AND
ITS MAJORITY HAVE RECEIVED THAT
MEANWHILE OVER IN THE SAINTED
SENATE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
RICHARD BURR OF NORTH CAROLINA,
REPUBLICAN, SAID TO A TELEVISION
INTERVIEW IN THE LAST DAY OR SO,
THAT THAT INVESTIGATION, WHICH
HAS BEEN THOUGHT TO BE VERY MUCH
MORE SOBER AND BIPARTISAN AND
BETTER HAD COME SO FAR AND
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME CONCLUSION.
THERE'S A GOOD REASON FOR THAT.
IN ALL LIKELIHOOD, THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
THERE'S BEEN NO EVIDENCE OF IT
SO FAR AND I THINK THAT PIECE OF
THEIR CONCLUSION IS PROBABLY
CORRECT AND I NOTICE THAT EVEN
ADAM SCHIFF OF CALIFORNIA WHO
HAS BEEN A DOGGED DISSENTER AND
A VERY PARTISAN ONE ON THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE, EVEN HE DENOUNCING
THE CONCLUSIONS, ALL HE SAID IS
THE INVESTIGATION SHOULD
CONTINUE.
HE DIDN'T SAY HE OR THE
COMMITTEE HAS EVIDENCE THAT
WOULD DISPUTE OR EVEN REFUTE THE
COMMITTEE'S CONCLUSION ON
COLLUSION.
HE CALLED IT A TRAGIC MILESTONE
BUT DIDN'T EXPLAIN WHY.
FINALLY, THE SPECIAL ELECTION IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
A DISTRICT OUTSIDE PITTSBURGH
THE PRESIDENT WON BY 20 POINTS.
SEEMS TIGHT TONIGHT.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
ARE WE INFLATING IT?
>> IT'S AN ELECTION THAT I WOULD
HESITATE TO DRAW MAJOR
CONCLUSIONS FROM.
THE SIGN COULD BE THE PROTEST
VOTE THAT WILL COME OUT TO VOTE
FOR THE DEMOCRAT BECAUSE
MR. TRUMP.
THERE'S NOT MUCH QUESTION ABOUT
THAT IN ADDITION, THEY HAVE THIS
YOUNG ATTRACTIVE CANDIDATE ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE, SOMEWHAT
DOWDY CHARACTER ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
THIS IS CONDUCTED IN THE SHADOW
OF THE DEPARTURE OF THE PREVIOUS
INCUMBENT THAT LEFT THEM IN A
SEX SCANDAL.
THAT CASTS A SHADOW OVER THE
PART NOMINEE.
SO BEAR THIS IN MIND, THIS IS AN
ELECTION TO FILL A SEAT BETWEEN
NOW AND NOVEMBER IN WHICH THERE
WILL BE A NEW DISTRICT BECAUSE
OF REDISTRICTING AND THIS
DISTRICT WILL GO AWAY.
SO LEGISLATIVELY, IT'S PRETTY
INSIGNIFICANT BUT WILL BE SEEN
AS A BELLWETHER DEPENDING WHO
WINS, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING THE DEMOCRAT
IS RUNNING AWAY FROM THE GUN
ISSUE, WHICH I THINK A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS THINK IS A WINNER FOR
THEM.
BUT NOT THIS ONE APPARENTLY.
>> YEAH, HE IS.
HE'S SAYING HE WON'T BACK NANCY
PELOSI FOR SPEAKER.